Next up, let's have a look at distance fields and how they can be used within materials.
So this is, I've got a slide 14, and you'll see this rather ominous black and white zone.
So I'm using a post-protest volume to sort of generate this
sort of visual interpretation of distance fields.
And if I hit simulate here, this is going to look a little bit better.
So you can see what's happening is we are getting a higher value around where two meshes are going
to intersect. So the concept behind distance fields is it is the distance you are from a
close edge to another surface. So as more surfaces become interconnected, you'll get a brighter colour.
Now this will be in the same value as if we were looking at the depth tests and custom depth tests.
The values aren't usually in zero to one, they're in sort of numbers of centimeters.
So if you plug this value directly in, you're going to get a really, really high value
and it's not going to be much use to you. But you can do a little bit of math to group
ocri in order to get some good effects out of it.
OK, so next, let's have a look at the different kind of effects you can generate.
So this is a force field type effect. You can see in this as the fields pass through the mesh,
I'm using the distance fields as a method of creating this sort of outline to make it look
like it's intersected it. So this is just sort of one good use of it in a relatively
sub-static material. Now, next up, what we have on slide 16 is this little sign.
And in order to see this function, you really need to play in the editor. So if you use the
A, W and S, S and D keys, you can move around in the space to jump.
You can see the effect of how this material is adapting to the environment around it.
I think it's most prominent when you can see it sort of coming over the edge here
as we move about. And it's got a couple of other just sort of little effects in it to
use the world position offset to make it bob up and down. But it can give you a really,
really pleasant sort of feeling of it adapting and sort of a meta ball if you've ever worked with
Blender. The material is adapting to the closeness of the outer elements.
Now, if I was to jump in and let's have a quick look at the sign material.
There's quite a bit in here, so I won't try and break it all down. But the primary bits
that we are interested in are the distance to nearest surface. So you can see here,
this is how I'm getting the distance field in there. So this is going to provide us with
a value which is in centimeters. And it's going to allow us to manipulate and edit materials
accordingly. I've used parameters in most cases here because it's really tricky to get those
numbers absolutely sort of spot on. But the distance to the nearest surface is what's
going to allow you to do these kind of things. Probably the easiest example is still
this force field. If I was to open it up and you can see that we have the...
you can see that we have the... where's the distance to? Yeah, the distance to the nearest
surface. And I'm just having to do some maths on it in order to build out a distance field mask.
So that is that is the maths that I've used in this instance just to create
the the mask around the distance field. So if I was to take that and plug that directly
into the emissive and then apply and simulate you'll be able to see when they pass through
you can see it's just that mask which is penetrating the the mesh.